Now the interesting question is, once I go to the
node that I think is going to give me the page
that I'm looking for, or at least information about the page
that I'm looking for. Whether it is, if it has it,
it's going to give it to me, or if it
doesn't have it, it's going to tell me that it is
on the disk. But, in either case, I'm going to get,
I'm hoping, I'll get exact information about this missing page from
this node which is supposed to have the
page foame directory, the PFD that corresponds with
this UID. Is that possible that I go to this guy, and he says no, I
don't have it. Yes, it is possible in two cases. One case is, let's say, while
this guy was sending this request over, this
guy has made a decision to evict that
page that corresponds to this UID because it had to make space for itself. In
that case, that UID may have been thrown away from the PFD. And if it has been
thrown away from the PFD, what he would have done is inform the guy who has
the ownership for this UID, this node is the owner for this UID. If he evicts
that page this guy has to tell this node that,
hey, you know what, I used to back this UID
in my PFD but I got rid of it. And, and I got rid of it by sending it to some
other node, let's say, node D. So that is something
that I have to communicate to this GCD, but it's a
distributed system. Things are happening asynchronously. He may not have
communicated that yet, that information is not there in the GCD
of this node. This is the owner for this UID space. But the owner
doesn't yet know that the PFD that corresponds to a particular
UID has moved to some other node out here somewhere. And if
it has moved to some other node, he will
know about eventually, but he doesn't have it at this
point. That's why this request was routed here, and
this guy says I don't have it. It can have
a miss. That's one possibility. Second possibility
is the uncommon case that the POD information
that I had is stale. When can that happen? That is when the POD is being
recomputed for the local area network as a
whole, either because there are new additions or
new deletions of nodes. And therefore we are
recomputing the redistribution of the UID space and
deciding which node is responsible for which UID. That can
happen. And in that case also, it is possible that
the information that I started with was incorrect. Because I
went here thinking that he has the GCD, he didn't
have it at that point, but it is changing. And
eventually I'm going to find out. So if there is a
mess, either case. The first case is, this guy replaced
that page, or the second case is, my POD information
misled me. Both cases, I'll have a miss. And I'll
say, oh, it was a miss. And I know that
is probably the uncommon case. I'm going to retry that,
by looking up my POD again. And by that time, the
POD may have been updated, I'll go to the right
GCD this time. Or, the GCD would have been updated
and so I'll go to the same GCD, but the
GCD will have the more relevant information of which PFD is
currently hosting it. So, I'll go to him in
order to get the page that I'm looking for.
But the important point I want to leave you with
is that the common case is when both the POD
and GCD are coresident on the same node. And
in that case, you don't have a network communication to
look up the GCD, and also the miss happening
when you do reach the PFD. That is also uncommon.
It can because happen because of replacement that has happened
on that node, or because the POD has changed. And this
is something that is going to happen relatively infrequently compared to
the activities that we're talking about in terms of page faults.